[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv and
recorded on thursday
february the 25th on this week's show
the latest in the snp psycho drama alex
salmond accuses nicolas sturgeon
and her allies of a concerted effort to
bring him down
the evidence he thinks supports this
claim which the spectator went to court
to publish
is still not being published by the
scottish
parliamentary inquiry into this very
murky affair
civil war might have broken out of the
top of the snp but it's hardly all unity
at the heart of
boris johnson's government when it comes
to the union katie balls will be here to
discuss this week's cover story
on how mr johnson could still lose the
union
and therefore his job we'll look at the
prime minister's route
to lock down easing which won't see
normality returning
kind of until june mid-june at the
earliest we'll speak to nav
tax professor robert dingle and finally
with the government using public
information ads to encourage compliance
rory sutherland the spectator's wikiman
columnist
takes a look at this genre of
advertising and asks
what makes it effect so all that to come
in the next hour
as always if you subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel and why
wouldn't you it's free
you'll never miss a program just click
the subscribe button or even click it
you can kick it if you want
but definitely click it at the bottom
right of the screen now
a very special thanks to charles stanley
for their
continued support of the week in 60
minutes this year
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms it's one
of the oldest companies
on the london stock exchange we're
delighted to
be partners with them now a
drama of shakespearean proportions is
unfolding north of the border
alex salmond and nicholas sturgeon used
to be political soul mates
she lived up to him he mentored her she
was his designated successor as first
minister
now simon is accusing his former protege
not just of misleading or even lying to
the scottish parliament
but being part of a scottish government
and snp
cabal designed to destroy him
sturgeon says there's not a shred of
evidence to support
his claims but her crown office has
censored key parts of his evidence
and her snp is arguing strongly that it
should not be published
of course it already has been by the
spectator
so why the fuss you might ask reasonably
well here's the answer because unless
the parliamentary inquiry
also publishes the evidence the inquiry
cannot consider it
when it comes to its conclusions clever
to break down the significance of this
week's events i'm joined by fraser
nelson the spectators editor katie balls
spectators deputy political editor and
alex masley our scotland editor
welcome to you all let's go straight
north of the border first alex
give us an update is alex salmond
now going to testify before the
parliamentary inquiry tomorrow
uh all the indications are that he is
going to appear
uh tomorrow friday morning but then of
course all the indications have been
that he would appear
on several previous occasions and uh
something at the last moment has always
come up that has made it
impossible for him to do so however this
time we are assured that he will
testify before the committee tomorrow uh
and then next
week nicola sturgeon will have her say
at long last her appearance
having been postponed on as many as half
a dozen
occasions as this committee has uh tried
to to make its
tortuous way through a sort of morass of
treacle
and made very little headway while
trying to do so uh so
this is after two two and a half three
years of this saga
finally coming to a head and the
implications
are possibly explosive um it is entirely
possible that this
could one day be seen as the as as the
few days
in which nicola sturgeon's career comes
to an abrupt end and with it
the all sorts of uh knock-on
consequences not just for may's
hollywood election
but for scotland and the future of the
united kingdom
itself i mean it is it is a fairly big
deal
if mr simon does appear and i perfectly
take your point we've been here before
on many an occasion and it hasn't
happened
but if it does this time alex
will he do we know yet if he will be
allowed to
speak to those parts of his submission
which the crown office wanted redacted
and parliament has
redacted because the parts that have
been censored if you like
really go to the heart of the claims
he's making against nicholas sturgeon
about misleading parliament
uh absolutely i mean one has to think
that
that the committee will be able to
inquire about this because
otherwise it seems to me that the point
of having mr salmond appearing is
sharply reduced or diminished and you're
right
that the committee is charged with
investigating just how the scottish
government managed to botch its own
investigation into the first two
complaints that were made by civil
servants against alex salmond
a procedure that he took to judicial
review
where the judge uh ruled that it was
unlawful
and tainted by apparent bias um that is
what the committee is investigating they
are not interested they are not capable
they are not charged with investigating
the grounds for those complaints against
salmon or the details of what took place
between him and
and various women ah but therefore as a
part of that
that one of the key questions it seems
to me um
is what did the first minister know
about this investigation and when did
she know it
she insists that she knew nothing of it
until april the 2nd
2018 when she was informed of it by alex
salmond
himself at a meeting at her house in
glasgow
now there is evidence from court and
other other areas which suggests that
actually nicola sturgeon knew about this
some days previously um and that
there was a meeting between alex
salmon's former chief of staff
and the first minister and members of
her office uh which was arranged
by the first minister's office precisely
to discuss the investigation
into the complaints against salmon and
that uh and the the
the the charges against him so if that
is the case
and we only have mr salmon's word and
those of his allies for it
then to the layman it looks as though
nicola sturgeon has been guilty of
misleading parliament and the media on
multiple occasions um
now she will argue that it's only three
or four days and it doesn't really
matter here very much but
it seems to me that it is quite possible
for nicola sturgeon to have had a much
greater awareness
of this investigation for some weeks
perhaps even months
earlier than she has hitherto said and
that means that really it is her
integrity her truthfulness that is the
matter for inquiry
uh in this regard um and and that it
seems to me poses a rather greater
problem for her
well certainly knowing weeks in advance
i think it would be reasonable to
conclude alex could come
to the meeting on this this crucial
month of march leading up to the
meeting on april the 2nd 2018 with alex
salmond in glasgow
which turned out to be a government
meeting rather than a party meeting
as originally claimed because her
husband turned up at the house but
didn't go to the meeting because
he thought it was a party a government
meeting and he's chief executive of the
party and didn't belong
there but we know that the meeting that
was fixed
between jeff aberdeen mr simon's former
chief of staff
and alex uh uh and and nicolas sturgeon
in hollywood in the first minister's
office the
that in itself had been the arrangements
for that had begun
with jeff aberdeen meeting her nicholas
sturgeon's chief of staff
at the beginning of march now surely it
beggars belief
that her chief of staff would not have
said
in fixing the meeting with jeff aberdeen
that the he's coming to see you first
minister
it surely beggar's belief that he she
wouldn't have said
and it's to talk about the complainants
against his behavior
uh well i'd rather agree with you there
andre yes um but then in the same way i
find it
extremely difficult to believe that you
have in late
late uh 2017 two civil servants
register concerns and then subsequently
complaints
about their experiences at the hands of
alex salmond and i find it quite hard to
believe
that nobody in the scottish government
thinks it is
sensible prudent or necessary to inform
the first minister of this
and yet that is something that we are
asked to believe
i find that quite incredible given what
i know about the closeness of the
snp about the way in which scottish
politics a very small
tightly knit circle of people in which
everybody knows everybody and everybody
knows a lot of other people's business
uh the way in which scottish public life
operates
leads me to think that it would be quite
extraordinary for the first minister
not to be included in some of those
discussions but that is what we are told
and
perhaps perhaps the first minister has a
satisfactory explanation for
all of this um she promises to deliver
that next week
she insists that at no point has she
done anything wrong or dubious or
improper
and that or her concern has always
solely been
to ensure that the complaints made
against her predecessor
are properly investigated that it would
have been a dereliction of duty
for her to have allowed those complaints
to go un
investigated if you like um and and i
think people can agree on that obviously
and they can
further agree and accept that this was
obviously in many ways a very difficult
um
moment and series of choices for nicolas
sturgeon to have to make
um but nevertheless the central issue at
play now is whether she has been telling
the truth to parliament or not and that
is quite distinct
from questions as to whether or not she
uh
you know sought to intervene in the
investigation
um you know so so you know the charge is
not actually one of any sort of
interference in the investigation
necessarily
but of not telling the truth or being
candid
about her involvement in the
investigation as
you know that old cliche you know the
cover-up is worse than the crime well
cliche cliches become such things for a
reason because they frequently contain
a degree of truth as you just said the
watergate question when did you know
what did you know and when did you know
it that was senator baker's
crucial question throughout the
watergate hearings
let me bring fraser in here now because
friends of us
something i think most of our viewers
won't understand
and that is that the scottish parliament
published alex simon's submission but
then under pressure from the crown
office
uh withdrew it agreed to a whole range
of redactions about some
quite crucial areas that alex and myself
have just been
talking about there and then republish
it with all these
redactions and yet
unredacted bar for one redaction the
whole submission
is on the spectator website people just
won't understand how these two things
fraser can exist in tandem well there's
two
extraordinary things about this the
first is of course why would you bother
redacting something already
in the public domain and the answer as
you said earlier andrew is that if it's
not published in their version of the
inquiry
been alex salmond can't really talk
about it it basically
censors it not just from his evidence
but from the evidence he's about to give
tomorrow and also it gives if it's
published it gives him legal cover
if if they've rejected it when alex
salmon feels he'll be legally exposed
because it's not like westminster
where anybody can say anything in a
westminster inquiry in the house of
commons
they've got legal cover they've got
parliamentary privilege that doesn't
exist
in scotland but the other extraordinary
thing is that the crown office
is giving instructions to parliament in
the first place
it's absolutely unthinkable but the
crown prosecution service
in and down here in london will be
telling the house of commons what they
can and can't publish
what lines of inquiry they should and
should not pursue they would regard it
as incendiary
if they would be given such advice and
from the director of public prosecutions
there was another point as well which
really comes to the the hearts of the
kind of separation of powers issue
here that the crown office which dick
gave his um
applied the pressure to the scottish
parliament has at its head
the lord advocate who's a member of
nicholas george's government who
has sat in several cabinet meetings with
her so here you've got a government
minister
in charge of the crown office giving the
snp's message
or the crown office is basically aligned
with the snp
now the reason andrew that we the
spectator went to the high court was to
clear up beyond doubt
that there was no legal impediment to
the whole story being told
to the truth being pursued it cost us a
fair amount of money going to
the high court and getting that advice
but you'd think
there that the crown office would have
no real justification
for saying to the scottish parliament no
no you've got to take away this and that
for legal reasons
because the high courts lady dorian had
made clear
but there were well there was no legal
impediment yet in defiance of the high
court
the crown office run by a member of
nicola sturgeon's government
has made this direction and the scottish
parliament has succumbed
so the question arises and also with
watergate
the other question of watergate was if
the american president is guilty of
something
could he be investigated was democracy
strong enough
in america to really follow the truth
wherever it left
the same question is being raised for
scotland now can the first minister
really be investigated or would she have
little powers levers she could pool
that would thwart that investigation
unfortunately is looking very much like
the latter
i must say it is among many remarkable
developments the
idea that the crown office in in our
case
when it appeared before lady dorian i
think probably the second
uh most senior judge in scotland uh
about our case
it raised not no complaints about
us continuing to have posted this salmon
submission minus the i think it was
paragraph 26
that they wanted out we took that out
and yet when the scottish parliament
does it
they go back fraser to the palm and say
no you can't put the whole chunks of
this you can't publish
even though they didn't raise that with
us and when the lord advocate yesterday
in the scottish parliament was asked
about this the head of the crime office
the person
as you say that sits in nicola
sturgeon's
cabinet when he was asked about what had
changed between not raising it in the
spectator case
and then putting the the heavies on the
scottish parliament
uh a week or so later he just didn't
answer the question
well if exactly his whole performance
there just showed how unaccountable he
really is
to parliament all of his answers were
very cursory
and he just didn't feel accountable but
then under the scottish system he
basically
isn't they can get away with this there
is of course
absolutely no answer to the question he
was asked like if
they were worried that alex salmon's
evidence somehow transgressed the law
somehow and exposed the claimants to
identification
of course they'd be writing to us they'd
be asking us to take it down or they
might have mentioned it to the high
court when this exact case was being
considered
but right now the crown office can act
not only with impunity but without any
accountability
but don't even feel compelled to answer
the questions
when they're in parliament because the
wiring of devolution is such
that the executive whoever's in power
has got incredible um ability to do
pretty much whatever
they want and that's why this episode is
not chilling it's
so chilling it's not chilling because
what alex says alexamen says is true
i've got no idea
of what he says is true or not it's
chilling because we're finding out how
easy it is to stop
parliament asking questions that the
government doesn't want
raised that's happened time and time
again shamelessly
and without any kind of come back at all
so far
i want to bring katie in a minute then
go back to alice before i do
the lord advocate could have answered
that question yesterday
but the answer i would believe the
correct answer
would have caused yet another crisis
because i think the correct answer is we
don't care that the spectators published
it
the important thing is the scottish
parliament doesn't publish it or
or doesn't publish the redactions
because that means the inquiry
uh cannot question alex simon about
these redactions
cannot question nicolas sturgeon about
the bits are redacted and
cannot take them into account when it
comes
to making its conclusions and yet that
part that was redacted is crucial
to alex simon's claim that the first
minister
misled parliament but it's not there in
the scottish parliament
and my understanding is can't be
discussed katie let me bring me in alex
quite rightly said in a sense that there
are two
main criticisms alex simon or
accusations
alex simon makes of nicholas sturgeon
one that she
lied to or at the very least misled
the scottish parliament over the what a
great question what did you know
when did you know it and the second is
that she was part of a kind of cabal
trying basically to destroy alex
sturgeon let's park that one
and go back to the misleading parliament
in london in westminster almost
certainly if a prime minister was found
to have done this
uh it's a resigning matter are you clear
there would be one in the scottish
parliament
no i think the expectation would be that
nick of the sturgeon
if she has found to mr parliament uh is
as you say a resignation offense i think
is widely seen as that humorous lead
parliament
even in westminster though when we
recently had a minister in former pretty
patel and the ministerial code
wasn't completely clear that that was
followed and but but i do think if you
speak to
figures in scotland scottish
conservatives they think this is
becoming increasingly
damaging for nicolas sturgeon but do
they think this is going to be the end
of her career
look everything is possible but i get
the greatest sense that they see this as
something that could cause a serious
dent in terms of the snp's reputation
nick of the sturgeon's reputation
personally
and it could be the start of an
unravelling rather than that moment
but it's unpredictable times of course
so there is always that chance but i
think
all the things we've seen so far in
terms of the
push to make sure the scottish
department cannot look or ask certain
questions shows what you are up against
when it comes to what you would expect
to be
the right thing to do alex what's your
view in
in what i guess we should say is the
unlikely event that the
parliamentary inquiry is quite explicit
that the first minister
did mislead or even lie to parliament
would she have to resign if that was the
conclusion
well ordinarily yes i mean you know
first ministers have had to resign for
much lesser offenses than that and other
scottish political figures even in the
short history of the scottish parliament
have also seen their careers
terminated for much flimsier offenses
than anything that nicholas sturgeon
might credibly be accused of um and so
you know if you view it from those
in that sense that you know there is
ample precedent for her going but
you know these are not the usual
circumstances
this is an extraordinary situation and
an extraordinary moment in scottish
history too
you know there is a election to holly
roode in may
an opinion poll today shows a little bit
of fragmentation of the snp support but
still suggests that the party would win
uh an overall majority in that uh
election with all that then entails in
terms of
uh the national question about
independence the future of the united
kingdom and so on and remember for
for an awful lot of voters that is a
much much more important and bigger
question
than the fate of nicola sturgeon or
whether she's telling the truth or not
um and so i suspect that she might well
feel that she could tough it out
if you like um because if she does if
she makes it clear that she wouldn't be
going anywhere
well who's actually going to do anything
who is in a position to
to actually change that reality and it's
not clear to me that there would be
anybody
in a position to do that you know that
obviously if it would be the case
would i think further undermine and
tarnish the respectability and the
authority
of the scottish parliament and of
scottish politics more generally
um but it is an unavoidable truth that
this is now becoming a very partisan
fight
it's not just a question of establishing
the truth of what happened or maybe
didn't happen
in this whole rather squalid affair it
has become a partisan fight with
conservative and labour msbs uh you know
demanding nicola sturgeon's head
essentially because they
see that this scandal might deliver it
to them
in a way that the electorate down them
will not
ask you this alex then i go to fraser
and then
i can let you two get on with your day
and
i'll keep katie hostage because i want
to ask her about what's happening inside
downing street about the union
so my question to you is this alex for
for a lot
of this story because you began by
saying it's been around for a long while
but it's been very much a kind of
hollywood bubble story it hasn't had
huge cut through to the general public
partly because
the scottish media has been curiously
reluctant to do much about it
am i right to detect that that's
changing a bit now
that the scottish media is doing a lot
more on this
and that it is because mr salmond and
nicola sturgeon
are now daggers drawn publicly attacking
each other publicly
that it's beginning now to have cut
through to the wider electorate
i i think on that latter point it has to
because you know you
suddenly see you know the bbc taking an
interest you see
the london broadsheets taking an
interest
uh you know having largely ignored this
story for
for you know two two and a half years um
so you know the you know plenty of
people in scotland have obviously been
writing a lot about it
um over the last period of time but it
has been difficult
to for to for the story to get much cut
through partly because it is very
complicated
um you know there isn't necessarily a
single soundbite charge to be leveled
against nicolas sturgeon until alex
salmon supplies it but then his
his charge against her is so
extraordinary it involves the
complete corruption of almost every
facet of scottish public life
if true it would be truly monstrous but
it is such a
such a large claim that i think plenty
of people will think well could that
possibly actually be
true um but nevertheless you know
this is now bubbling up you know it is
unavoidable partly because you finally
have
um the the pair of them if you like
getting in the ring together like uh
like a boxing match that has been
scheduled or rumored for a long long
long period of time without ever
actually
quite being made now it is being made
and so now is the time for people who
haven't been paying attention
for the last couple of years and i
understand why they might not have been
because plenty of other things have been
happening in the world i mean
we have had this pandemic thing um you
know
but now is the time for for even people
who have not been paying attention
enough until now
to actually do so because it is a proper
heavyweight contest
and fraser my final question to you i
mean westminster
hasn't even been a spectator in this
it's largely ignored it
until perhaps the past couple of weeks i
mean i noticed
liam fox uh from scottish but
tori representing an english consistency
raising it in the commons yesterday
saying
the the the the scottish devolution
uh system was created by the house of
commons by the westminster parliament so
don't we have any uh say over what is
going on there don't we have any
powers of scrutiny or oversight i
thought that was interesting
and i wrote in in an article that you
know if
if texas was behaving in this sort of
way uh
the u.s government would have sent in
the feds by now to look at first
amendment rights breaches and
various other things i mean is
westminster getting more interested
fraser
yes and what i thought was particularly
interesting was the reply
that liam fox got from the then deputy
speaker eleanor lang also ascot
she was saying that yes this house the
house of commons is always concerned
about
keeping up the standards of democracy a
hint
that the house of commons as an
institution might well take an interest
in its creation the scottish parliament
to see if things have gone wrong there
now you see this is a theme amongst not
just the scots
in parliament but all ministers they're
working out that if they care about the
uk as much as the s p cared about
scotland they should of course
be feeling the pain of a nervous system
of an island if something goes wrong
in scotland it should absolutely
resonate in westminster
now katie reveals in her cover piece for
this week's magazine
that there are now plans to use powers
seen at brexit for the uk government to
go into scotland and start to sponsor
more things
directly for example it could say okay
there's huge drugs deaths in glasgow
so maybe we can work with the glasgow
council to come up with more treatment
centers so the council would appeal
directly to westminster for funding it
might not get
from edinburgh and in that way the uk
government can be a little bit more
a uk government rather than seeing
scotland as a foreign country
of which it knows little and understands
less
well let's see if if they do i think
it's now got their
attention and the way it didn't have
even two or three weeks ago
fraser alex i know you're both busy i'm
gonna let you go
uh but i'm gonna hold on to katie for
just a little bit more because
katie's done the uh cover story of the
spectator this week and it's
about what's been happening inside 10
downing street vis-a-vis the union
uh you would think perhaps that with a
kind of civil war
going on in scotland at the very top of
the snp
that would be good you news for the
unionist cause
and in theory it probably is a bit
however
downing street's been having its own
civil war over how to
keep the union how to handle the snp how
to put the cause
for the union and katie has written
about that
tell us more katie because it would seem
that there's
actually been deep divisions in downing
street over
how to meet the nationalist threat
yes uh not to be outdone the westminster
government have kept themselves
rather busy with their own factional
infighting in recent weeks
and we have a situation where there that
is now affecting the union policy
um so there have been various reports
over the weekend about boris johnson's
court or queen carries court depending
on
who you read and but ultimately what
happened last friday was that oliver
lewis
resigned as the head of the union unit
after just two weeks in the job
and earlier that month that actually
lost luke graham as head of the union
unit
uh so two gone in one month which i
think does just point to the
disharmony when it comes to how you get
a
coherent union strategy in downing
street that works for other departments
now the departure of oliver lewis was as
much to do with personalities
and the vote leave faction at the rise
of the govites or friends of carrie
simmons
and all uh boiling up but when you
look at where that leaves us now there's
a situation where oliver lewis had a
strategy
one that he was supposed to present to
government advisers
um the evening that he instead quit his
job uh which was an aggressive strategy
to take on the snp
try and stop them from winning a
majority in the scottish parliament
elections
close the door firmly on a referendum
have a 40-person strong union unit
a little bit like a vote leave campaign
uh some would say
and but this is all gone now and instead
we are
getting a cabinet committee the end of
the union unit as far as we can tell or
at least as we have known it
and a debate has reopened on how exactly
you should have this message
on on the union a gove approach which is
a softer approach
or a more confrontational one and i have
to say right now very few people know
so despite this change of personal i
understand there's oliver lewis that you
write about mccover's story he was meant
to be
heading up the sort of the union unit he
was only in the job for two weeks
or something there was as you say this
disagreement
michael golf hailing from aberdeen
himself wanting to love bomb the scots
with the union propaganda
uh mr lewis wanting a much take no
prisoners
much tougher line in dealing with the
smp
and the and the separatists
we've seen he's now gone his predecessor
went
before that michael gove's position
seems to change every second week in
terms of what he does for this
government we don't know yet you're
telling us katie
what the johnson government strategy is
for preserving the union no
cabinet ministers believed they
understood the strategy because oliver
lewis has started to present it to them
i think there are some that quite like
this strategy because i thought it was
simple
it wasn't uh too overly intellectual it
would uh you know
finally take a tough approach to the snp
no more apologizing no more devolution
things like that or you know giving more
powers and but now you have a point
where it does
appear that michael goes position is in
the ascendancy on the union
we're hearing that uh boris johnson
might soften his tone
start talking about a reckless
referendum rather than a
never referendum and i think as soon as
you start talking about a reckless
referendum you're moving to the michael
gove approach which is
say no to a referendum but because it is
not the time now
rather than there could never be a
referendum because it was once in a
generation
which is more the lewis view and there
is a cabinet committee where we are
going to see the prime minister
take charge apparently this is now the
time for him to take charge on the union
and different views amongst the
ministers on it so i still think that if
you look at it in the sense that
it really is a perilous moment for boris
johnson if nicolas sturgeon wins the
majority in the scottish parliament
elections
matters at the point in a way could be
taken out of his hands it becomes an
issue of legality it could go to the
courts
um so this is a very important time yet
there is no
cohesive uh strategy or agreement right
now and
we still seem to be vaguely in the
debate stage
uh there is one area final question to
you to where
where a light bulb seems to have gone on
in downing street
or in government and that is that it's
it's suddenly dawned on them properly
because they all belong to the
department of slow learners that
it doesn't matter how much money extra
money you pump into scotland
if you do it through the scottish
government run by the snp
they will say two things one they'll
take the credit for the money
when they spend it and secondly they'll
say it's not enough
doesn't matter how much is it's not
enough so we get the credit for spending
it
but by the way it's not enough because
that miserable westminster didn't give
us as much
as we need they've now realized that in
the way the european union used to spend
money directly and you would
see the little european union flag
brought to you by the european
commission or whatever
that the london government is going to
spend money directly in scotland
is that correct yes and this is an area
where there is broad agreement
but again a disagreement on tone but
ultimately special powers from brexit
from the
internal market bill i mean that uh one
idea that boris johnson is very
keen on is the idea of local councils
being able to apply directly to
westminster for funding for projects
and as you say you cut out the scottish
parliament but it's not so much a power
grab
so it could be accused of this because
it's an additional thing and so
you could say we are funding this uh you
know this drug center in glasgow because
you need that roll and taking
powers away is adding powers on in terms
of what westminster can do
and it has a lot of support i think the
question is do you say it in the sense
of
we are funding this drug center because
the smp is useless and that's why we've
stepped in
that's one approach or the gove approach
i think would say we're funding this
because
we at westminster love scotland and you
deserve it
they still have a lot to decide yes it's
quite clear including who's actually
gonna
head up uh the pro-union campaign
uh katie thanks for joining us a great
cover story it really takes the lift off
the lid off what's been happening inside
downing street so it's well worth the
read
uh back to pandemic we managed to avoid
it in this broadcast for a little bit
but there's no avoiding it
in england the prime minister's finally
announced the long-awaited route to
easing
the lock down under it most most covered
restrictions
in england will be gone by june the 21st
that's the plan
anyway it's slower than some we're
hoping but just how costly will four
months be
of lockdown joined now by kate andrews
our economics correspondent she's editor
of our daily
lunchtime briefing which has got lots of
stuff about covert in it
uh it runs up all you need to know about
the latest covert numbers
so let's go straight to kate thanks
andrew
all of the cova data continues to move
in the right direction
as you can see from this first slide the
seven day rolling average for cases
is now back to where we were in roughly
late september last year
hospitalization emissions are down to
where they were in early december
as england was coming out of its second
national lockdown
and the rolling seven-day average for
deaths is back to the level
that it was that we saw in early
november
last year now in the wake of these
plummeting figures the prime minister
announced england's road map out of
lockdown
and it can be described as a cautious
pathway out of these covert restrictions
over the next four months
while schools head back on the 8th of
march the rule of 6 outside
is still over a month away with other
key dates down the road as well
including the 12th of april for
non-essential retail and hospitality
outdoors to reopen
the 17th of may 4 indoor hospitality and
then the big date the 21st of june in
which we're hoping to see socializing
and life events
be able to go back to normal
restrictions lifted but there are some
big caveats here including several
reviews
one around social distancing measures
which will have a huge impact on
business depending on which way that
goes and the other around the use of
covet certificates which i think is a
fancy way of saying domestic vaccine
passports
now this pathway has been made possible
as the prime minister said
by the vaccine factor despite slowing
down over the past few days the uk's
rollout of vaccines continues to storm
ahead
consistently ranking in the top five
countries in the world
for a rate of population vaccinated and
it's thought that this rollout is going
to pick up in the coming weeks when more
supply
is expected to manifest if and when all
this data continues to move up and down
in the right directions
more pressure is likely to mount on
boris johnson especially from his own
party
over his road map timetable he promised
that it would be driven by
data not dates so some were already
asking why that doesn't include moving
the timetable forward
if the data proves really positive so
here's some of the graphs that those
eager to reopen
faster will be pointing to despite
having a relatively low rate of covert
infections right now compared to the
rest of europe
the uk is under one of the strictest set
of coveted measures for many people
some especially on the prime minister's
back benches this doesn't quite add up
with the data especially with such
a successful vaccine rollout which has a
third of the adult population in the uk
including the elderly and the most
vulnerable having already received at
least one of their jabs
furthermore there are trade-offs that
lockdown has always presented
including the impact on non-coveted
health problems the
education of young people mental health
and much more
and this map here illustrates the excess
mortality rates among the under 65 in
europe who we know are much less likely
to dive covered 19
and this map certainly reflects the
impact of the virus yes but also the
impact
of lockdown measures and the unintended
harms that they can
cause and then of course there's the hit
to the economy
earlier this month the office for
national statistics confirmed what we
already had evidence for for some time
that the uk's economic hit was among the
worst of the big economies in 2020
with gdp falling by nearly 10
and we expect to see another dip as we
get figures for q1 this year
reflecting the lockdown that we are
currently in so the chancellor has a lot
to think about
and more in in the budget next week
but we'll have a lot more information
next week for our budget special
right here on spectator tv for now back
over to you andrew
i'll miss that spectator tv special next
week on
the budget and there'll be lots of
online coverage
next week as the budget unfolds uh as
well
uh let's turn now to professor robert
dingle he's a sociologist at nottingham
trent university he does a thing or two
about how
you respond to pandemics he's advised
the government on pandemic response for
many years
he sits on a nerve tank that's the
government advisory group on new and
emerging
respiratory virus threats he's appearing
today in a personal capacity
uh we're delighted to welcome him to
spectator tv
professor dunbar is the government not
right
to be a bit cautious uh
about coming out of lockdown so that we
don't end up back in it
or we don't meet the unknowns as what's
your overall view of the strategy
well i find it rather puzzling that the
the government has spent a great deal of
money on purchasing vaccines
rolling vaccines out that we have very
clear evidence from the clinical trials
and from the experience so far and from
the published work from israel
about how extraordinarily successful
vaccines are at
reducing deaths reducing hospital
hospitalizations
and generally transitioning uh
the infection to somewhere comparable
with the other 30 or so respiratory
viruses that have afflicted humanity
since
since forever and yet we don't quite
believe it
you know the data are there the data are
baked in
the improvements uh are rapidly coming
through the system
and yet we have this continual
insistence on well
things might go wrong we should be doing
this just
in case you know we cannot possibly be
too cautious
without really taking account of all the
collateral damage that's being done
i mean your slides just there pointed to
the excess deaths from cancer heart
disease other conditions
they pointed to the economic damage
there's all the damage that's been done
to children and their education
we should really be attempting to move
as fast as is reasonably practicable
rather than thinking well we must drag
everything out until
the very last person who wishes to be
vaccinated has been vaccinated
and has had another two or three weeks
to acquire immunity
and another three or four weeks until
we've crunched all the data
do you uh have a view then on on where
the government could move more quickly
out of lockdown lockdown and move more
quickly
towards at least a semblance of
normality what should it be doing
in your uh personal view that it's not
doing at the moment
well i think we could be moving much
faster once the
first phase of the vaccination program
is completed
somewhere around in the second half of
april
by that time we've taken out 90 98 of
the mortality risk
almost as much of the severe illness
risk
there's a little bit more in the under
fif
in the fort over 40s the 40 to 50 year
olds
but i mean that could be marked up
fairly quickly
so we're then saying well why would we
lock up a low-risk population for the
summer
rather than thinking about the maximum
number of restrictions that we can
remove
early in may you might say well it's
only
six or eight weeks coming forward but
those six or eight weeks are
going to make a great difference to the
economy they're going to be
an opportunity for the health service to
get going on the
catching up with the backlog of elective
surgery at a time when
business is getting quieter there's a
chance for the
overstressed staff of the health service
to you know get a little bit of space to
relax and recover
and i really don't see the justification
for
postponing everything in way
way into the summer when
there is obviously one run small risks
but there are tolerable risks of
moving much more quickly so what did you
make of the sage
warning the famous sage advisory body to
the government with neil ferguson
probably the most famous member of it on
that saying this week that if you ease
too much before easter it could lead to
55
000 more deaths they projected what do
you say when you see something like that
well i think it's very hard to see where
these numbers are coming from
it the problem with models is always
that they're only as good as the data
that you put into them
and the assumptions you make to you to
join that data
up and the the modeling
that we've seen so far it's made
unrealistic assumptions about
the uptake of the vaccination and the
effectiveness of the vaccination
and the models haven't really been
corrected to
to allow for that it's made unrealistic
assumptions about fatality rates
which have been falling with the
improvements in treatments
since last year and
you can play with the numbers you can
produce a reasonable worse case
but we tend not to hear what's the
reasonable best case
and since we're heading down towards you
know maybe a hundred deaths a day from
covid within the
the the next couple of weeks it's very
hard to see where all those excess
deaths are going to come from
do you see any sign in the government's
announcements and in his deliberations
that uh it could take this view that
it it begins down the the path that it
has
already explained but it said it looks
and says hey this is
actually going better than we thought um
we could speed this up a bit
is there any chance that could happen
well i think there are certainly
opportunities for that
i mean if the you know if the lines on
the graph continue in the same direction
for another two or three weeks
i would imagine that some conservative
mps will be asking very serious
questions about
whether they should vote for the renewal
of some of the powers at the end of
march
and i but i think the position is quite
clear
that the government will only move
faster if there are people pushing them
to do so
um and the people pushing them to do so
will be pushing against some very
formidable obstacles
uh in terms of you know the risk
aversion of some ministers the risk
aversion some scientists
um and i i think this sort of
sense that you know the political elite
the scientifically the countries they
lead
have really been very comfortable you
know we could all work from home
you know we've got big houses and we've
got gardens and we're really
disconnected from the lives of the
the people who are serving us the people
who are doing the deliveries
working in the shops working the food
processing plants
um and you know they deserve to have
their lives thought about too
and what it would take for you
for them to be released from the the
sort of confinement that that we've
we've imposed over the last year or so
it's certainly true that those coming up
with the confinement and not those who
bear the brunt of that
confinement i think that's true in the
political and the scientific
elite and the media elite as well
they're all not bearing the brunt
of it my guess would be that the prime
minister's
instincts would be to listen to you
rather than to other experts but he's
overwhelmed overcome
by what i would call the precautionary
principle
that as a politician is better
he is over cautious than takes what
might be seen
as a bit of a gamble with the kind of
advice you would give
well i think it's one of the interesting
things andrew is that that phrase
precautionary principle has been used so
incorrectly all the way through
i mean when it was originally coined in
the the 1990s
i i was doing work on this in connection
with genetically modified crops
the precautionary principle says
basically you don't do
stuff unless you've got a very thorough
appraisal
of the potential harms as well as the
potential benefits
and all the way through we've really
failed to give as much attention to the
harms of policies
as we have to the uh alleged benefits
so we've never really had this this sort
of balanced
look at what is happening to society
to the economy to the mental health of
the people as a result of the
various control measures now in part
that's because
the whole sage network was set up with a
single issue focus
you know stop covid and
the people involved with it are not
asked to consider the wider impact of
their actions
and i think that that has skewed the
advice coming to government
it's meant that there's been perhaps
less open debate
than there should have been uh within
the scientific community as
as much as within the political
community and that
the result of that is this sort of drift
towards
you know if the objective is curbing
covered at
all costs then in a sense all costs
become justified
and what people like me i suppose are
trained to do
as sociologists is to put covid into a
context
to say that there's a societal pandemic
here as well as a biomedical pandemic
and that societal pandemic looks a bit
different and it
should point us towards a rather
different approach to the policies
which is which which has a more perhaps
a better balance between the intended
and the unintended consequences
it's what we in economics would call a
full cost benefit analysis
the whole policy professor we'll leave
it there i know you've got to get away
you have a busy
day uh we thank you for putting your
your case so coherently
and giving our viewers something to
think about different from
what they're hearing from government
professor dingwell there thank you for
being
on spectator tv now older viewers until
we've got a few you might remember
things like
the tufty club the green cross code
public information campaigns from the
60s and the 70s teaching kids
like me at the time everything from how
to cross the road to taking
uh rubbish with another was not to
litter you know what i'm talking about
some of you want have a look at this
stop then stand on the pavement near the
curb and look all round for traffic
and listen i hear a noise
says bobby
when the lorry has gone they all look
round and listen again
all the traffic has gone now so we walk
straight across
looking and listening all the time but
always with mummy
says mrs fluffy tail so why am i talking
about this
well in this week's issue rory
sutherland the spectators wikiman
columnist
vice chairman of advertising company
ogilvy writes about these public
information campaigns and how they
worked
uh why they worked what was it about
them and
uh what we can therefore use in the age
of covert
and the pandemic of lockdowns rory you
brought back
many memories in your column
in the magazine i remember these as well
we all knew them as kids
did we even knew we knew the rhymes and
the songs
looking back when you think it was an
age of
where advertising or public information
was not
nearly as sophisticated as we think it
is now
actually it was pretty sophisticated and
pretty effective
yeah i mean i think the interesting
thing is that a very simple insight
which i think anybody who has children
will understand is that your children
don't listen to a word you say uh they
almost
discount any information that emanates
from parents
but an animated cat as in charlie says
or the green cross code man can be made
to work
or indeed tufty the squirrel for younger
children
i think there's a very interesting wider
question here which is that government
is so
dominated by lawyers and economists that
it looks to solve every problem either
through
legal compulsion or through economic
incentives
and outside a pandemic or an emergency
it loses sight of the power simply to
cajole and persuade
in a helpful way you know government has
fairly large
powers of persuasion simply because if
we're encouraged to do something
for the public good monarchy actually
performed this role with the
introduction of
variolation so merry workley montague
persuaded the royal family to
inoculate their children against small
ponds and it became the fashion
and i think um i think the excessive
dominance of
lawyers and economists has a significant
problem in that they always define every
problem first of all in legalistic or
economic terms and forget the power of
voluntary collective action
it's interesting to people are always
very wary of what was called the nanny
state
spectator readers above all i would
suggest are very wary
of the nanny state but when you see
these the tafty club and the
the the green giant whatever when you
see these
you don't really think of them as nanny
state and i don't think we did at the
time either we think of them as
if this is sensible and helpful advice
that will be good for me
and good for society i mean there is
presumably i mean if you take the
example i gave in the article of a piece
which featured it was actually done by
the british heart foundation but it
featured vinnie jones
telling people how to administer help to
someone
who is suffering a heart attack cpr
and everybody assumed completely wrongly
that this meant mouth-to-mouth
resuscitation
and i'm sure plenty of people died
because of social embarrassment
you know it's one thing to actually
stand on top of someone and pump their
heart
fairly vigorously and rhythmically it's
another thing to put your mouth
straight onto theirs so that was simply
a useful bit of information
which we're all better off knowing and
given that the government spends 45
percent of gdp
and yet it has an ad budget which is
smaller than spec savers and b and q
combined
all i'm saying here i'm not suggesting
this solves everything but that we're
under communicating
almost certainly and you know there
would be ways of encouraging people to
make bet you know not
not to miss doctor's appointments other
things which
can be established as a useful social
norm what was interesting is that
deirdre mccloskey who's generally a
right of center
economist agrees with me in this that
actually she's in favor
there was an economist called eleanor
ostrom who won the nobel prize the first
woman to do so and until recently the
only woman to win the nobel prize for
economics which i think is significant
in itself
and she spoke quite a lot about how you
design
societies and groups so as to maximize
cooperation
and i i describe that as akin to
painting the lines on a car park
okay okay even you know fanatical
libertarians don't mind when they go
into a car park they may prefer it's a
privately run car park
but they don't mind that someone paints
lines on the on the
tarmac okay i mean if you want to be an
absolute psychopath you can park at the
diagonal lacrosse team
but it just helps everybody behave in a
way that solves a coordination problem
and so i think there's far more room for
what you might call painting the
chevrons on the motorway
so just an interesting very recent
example we've spent a lot of money on
smart motorways
and they're not an altogether bad idea
but not a pennies being spent
teaching people how to use them it's
true if i don't think most people know
what a smart motorway is
you don't know what it is they come onto
a motorway there's some bizarre gantries
now
if you've spent a billion dollars on
roads it isn't that crazy to spend 10
million explaining how they work
and so an example would be actually the
smart motorways there's a deeply
counter-intuitive thing which is
by minimizing congestions and
by minimizing tailgating the slower you
drive the sooner you arrive at your
destination
now it takes a bit of a leap of the
imagination to understand that principle
because we generally drive
on the principle that the faster we go
the quicker we'll get there
but if smart motorways both had a
maximum speed and a recommended speed
and you explain to people if you obey
this injunction at the recommended speed
you're much less likely to end up in
gridlock and therefore you might arrive
sooner i think people would buy into the
general notion
but there's been no attempt to do that
how would you compare
the quality of our public information
messages
now compared to the historic ones that
we were talking about are they as good
or were they better than it's
interesting because
this is the distinction i make between a
bossy state or a nanny state and a
useful state
now i'll give you a little example you
may not have thought of this but
when you go on holiday you may leave
your car keys
somewhere in the hallway and one of the
biggest forms of theft now and the
police particularly hate it because it
counts as two crimes
is people break into homes when people
on holiday not worth stealing their
television anymore
there's ebay second-down electrical
equipment is worthless
okay but they steal the car keys and the
next thing is the cars on some
ship to turkey or russia or something
now
if you could simply tell people and
remind them when they go on holiday hide
your car keys
now you don't need everybody to do that
okay
if 30 40 50 of people start doing it
that crime is no longer worth committing
because you've now got to break into 15
homes to find one set of usable car keys
and so there's an awful lot of
improvement we can make on the margin
now the problem with only using
economics and only using legal
compulsion
is quite often there are unintended
consequences
and the law ends up hurting as many
people as it benefits i'm very
uncomfortable about putting the price up
on cigarettes
because the remaining what you might
call
you know the remaining hardcore smokers
tend to be disproportionately poor
yes yes it will work but at the price of
impoverishing families
so that would be an example where the
economic approach
might end up actually punishing as many
people as it benefits
and so we've got to be really alert here
and actually at some level there are
many many things where you just have to
operate at the margin
and so rory just finally we're coming
out of the
pandemic uh we hope uh
some think it should be quicker others
are happy to go to speed the government
has outlined what we're hoping that the
economy will pick up as well we're
hoping that the vaccines will work and
the pandemic
will never be eradicated completely but
it will be something that we're
on top of now what would be a good
public service
message to encourage this process
um you could encourage people to take
advantage
very weirdly actually i went to um
zoom the company about two two years ago
before the pandemic and said
what would you charge to give an account
to everybody in the uk
in other words rather than being a b to
b company you became a b
to g company so one useful thing we
could do
is encouraging some degree of remote
working
and also encouraging companies to hire
more widely
because actually the concentration of
wealth in london doesn't really matter
if the salaries are being spent in
bradford
okay yes to a great extent
if we want a leveling up agenda we have
a technology here which we're sitting on
which could help attain that end now you
can't mandate for that
i think it's fair to say i you could
incentivize it but it would be
slightly dubious but what you
undoubtedly could do is you could set an
example and generally encourage the
practice
as being economically beneficial very
interesting let's hope
somebody in government is watching and
takes uh that up
and of course for any aspiring actors
who think
that public information films are
beneath them you point out worry
that the giant in the green cross
code the toe the six foot seven chap he
went on to become
darth vader he started off working with
a colleague of mine on
bull worker direct response
advertisements
graduating to the green cross code man
and ended up as the body
not the voice of darth vader and that's
vital to understand because he had a
strong bristolian accent
and the world's not yet ready for a
super villain who goes actually
i'm your father luke
even i know that's another person even i
know that darth did not come from
bristol
rory great to have you on spectator tv
thank you for your uh column this week
great stuff that's it for this week
thanks to all our guests and again
a very special thanks to our sponsor
charles stanley
for sponsoring the week in 60 minutes
here on spectator tv
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest firms in the london
stock exchange
as always send us any thoughts you may
have spectator tv
spectator dot co dot uk and join us
again
next week bye bye
[Music]
you